you know it's funny when I look at the
biggest areas where people have been
cutting back it's forty percent of mint
users say they spend less on restaurants
and cook more at home and a full ink
ninety percent of people say they've
actually changed their spending habits
so I think at least four people in their
20s and early 30s the biggest problem
area is probably restaurants coffee
shops sort of your going out budget
getting lunch every day getting coffee
in the morning or the afternoon every
day those the sort of daily habits that
maybe you don't realize so sometimes I
wonder from a psychological perspective
if people have sort of a food and
beverage addiction I I'm typically a
just drink water kind of guy I was a
bodybuilder in high school so I used to
food to me was there are this many grams
of carbohydrates and proteins and I need
these micronutrients in order to grow
and to be fit and I I ate in order to
live not live in order to eat and I
think most people are the opposite and
so it sounds weird but the food that I
eat it doesn't doesn't make a big
difference and it never has so I've
saved a ton of money not buying a lot of
alcohol not that I going out to
restaurants too much so I think it's
part of our culture and it's part of a
social activity more than anything else
the other thing is I think we're in a
very consumer-focused culture where
you're almost taught that in order to be
happy or satisfied you have to spend on
the latest clothes gadgets whatever and
I think half the time it's in order to
impress other people you know the way
you dress or the car you drive or what
you spend its to impress other people
with how I get successful and rich you
are
but you're not and you shouldn't and who
gives a damn what other people think
anyway so that mentality i think is very
destructive it's it's the mentality of
being a second hander of carrying too
much what other people think that's an
odd thing to say maybe when we're
talking about the psychology of saving
but I think it that has more to do with
it than anyone imagined